[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going my Bros welcome back to I
uni which of course means blue dildo in
Korean this is a Japanese horor game and
I realize now thank you guys for the
suggestions with the save and all that
and I can't I got about like 30 message
telling me so yeah thanks I found the a
bedroom key now this [__] is going to
chase us no uh it's so creepy okay we're
good no don't go down that's what she
said I mean what
okay yes go go go go go go go hide here
Hide here oh [__] it's creepy as hell
that's a surprised I got away all the
cows
everywhere okay huh I used the bedroom
key where did I even find the bedroom
key there's got to be something in here
hello
no bed pillows
pillows yes oh what is this hello I
don't even know what this is this a
piano look who p period on the
piano I ah look in here oh look I find
it's a
key it says uh I don't even
know I don't understand and thing maybe
the piano will tell me no it doesn't
tell me
anything un look oh we're here now okay
let's see the door was locked can we go
here what is this I found the item
Chief I don't even know oh maybe I can
use the handkerchief on the piano to
wipe off the period probably yeah
saying okay ham cleaning Ladi so it's
okay let's use the h no it doesn't work
crap okay let's go down that's what you
said he said what okay we never checked
oh what is this I can feel I'm going to
say cuz something bad will happen the
door is
LED okay a ah not again no I got to go
a game over a good thing I saved wow it
should be psychic or something all right
again
okay here's go oh [__] it's so ugly ah
go go go P him no it's out me oh [__]
[__] are you kidding me I totally made
it up the stairs what the what the freak
FR okay one more time one more time
we're going to
celebrate Fu CB Dance free we going to
Cate Cate Dance free one
more no no no no stop we again we again
ah
[__] it's impossible what do we want
from me let's try the ah F Dam Jesus
Christ I don't even know
hello okay we're good no we're not good
let's go
hand oh it's open it's open go go hide
in the
toilet no come
on oh no no it's not back
a no no it's not fair where should I go
okay go go go go go go go go go go oh
[__] it's so creepy I hate you stop
following me stop it's not
fair no yes go down the hall Ah that's
what she said I guess ah hater is got a
hate he is going to hate he couldn't
even find me now I guess we go back to
where we were oh wait the bathroom is
open now we can go here H let's see here
oh yes look I found I found the item
Philips head screwdriver perfect maybe
we can use it on the piano or something
I don't know all right let's see what's
in here makeup I found soap perfect I
can wash my butt my hairy butt what it's
not hairy whatever
okay go we were in
there I will save cuz I was pretty
awesome at jumping there I mean running
same thing
basically okay did we say hi to him oh
you can hide you can hide you can hide
why did you tell me oh I'm seriously
pissed off I didn't know you could hide
from him okay let's see here oh I know
where we're going to go uh we're going
to go down and then up yes see see all
right and then we're going to go here
cuz we no you can't go there what the
[__] oh well yes let's go and see what's
in the closet there's nothing there is
absolutely nothing actually there's
something I found lighter okay soap
lighter and stuff we could make
something good okay let's go and check
the piano I want to go to the piano wipe
the stupid period stupid period on the
piano okay let's do it piano period go
initiate piano period no okay it's not
working okay uh that's all the time I
had for day with I onlyi I'm sorry I
have shorter videos right now but uh I'm
like I'm still moving a lot I'm really
busy but uh I promise I'll do longer
videos in the future but
that's it
[Music]
bye okay let's Venture further and
darkness what the [__]